regardez on va faire un nouveau jeu
s'appelle ici baba regarder je vous
montre d une qu'on a fait nous mêmes
vous essayez de trouver là dessus chez
vous vous jouez également regarder
regardez cette une
eric il en veut une plus grosse que
christian eric et qu'est ce que à quoi
correspondent ces attaques jean pascal
eric vers une plus grosse cagnotte
quelle crise à
ah ah ah ouais ouais allait alléger la
presse que je donne je donne il veut un
plus grand nombre de victoires que
christian une plus grosse des cris au
nom d'allah c'est quoi une tour aussi qu
il faut il faut un barbecue chaque fin
de semaine de tournage j'avais vu une
lourdeur par m non mais franchement on
sert à rien j'ai passé une série de
victoires tout simplement merci vous je
donne le point à kelly oui c'était pas
du rhin alors je vous le dis iric n'a
pas hésité à tacler l'ancien champion du
jeu dans une interview à télé star si
vous avez la télé si vous aimez les
stars vous adorez télé star bien entendu
il vous explique tout ça et regardez moi
je pense qu'eric il va pas de cris il a
battu christian en nombre en 15 ans gars
il n'a pas battu en nombre de
participations regarde depuis plusieurs
mois eric est devenu un visage connu des
fidèles de jean luc reichmann et son jeu
les 12 coups de midi avec 168
participation et 839 1794 euros de gains
se mettre 2010 semble en bonne voie pour
faire tomber les records les uns après
les autres génomes m est très riche je
dirais que sa cagnotte estime à
l'antenne depuis le 21 novembre 2019
le breton semble avoir réponse à tout il
a déjà dépassé le précédent champion
paul en nombre de victoires et de gains
se positionnant ainsi sur la seconde
place du podium des plus grands
champions
et à la première place tout très
controversé christian quesada est
toujours là s'il avait passé eric en
valeur de gains il n'a pas encore battu
son record établi à 193 participation
dans télé star le candidat a précisé
qu'il aimerait bien battre quesada lui
lançant au passage un petit pic
il est arrivé à 193 participation
j'espère le dépasser je ne crois que ça
ne ferait pas plaisir qu'à moi
d'ailleurs
alors il parviendra t'il réponse dans 25
émissions alors oui il a raison parce
que quesada il est médiatiquement mort
mais reste une ombre au tableau candidat
il restera toujours affilié à l'émission
de jean-luc reichmann donc terrain et la
production ils veulent qu'une chose qui
pulvérise le record wii et qu'il soit le
premier avant tout est très utile
d'ajouter cette phrase c'est ça va de
soi donc ouais ça vous a pas plus apte à
choquer moi tout ce qui se comprend sans
qu'on ait besoin d'appuyer je préfère ça
se fait que vous êtes le maire sur tout
cas quelle puissance et chérie regard
des prochaines infos c'est sûr denis
brogniart denis brogniart
cette photo a failli lui coûter la vie à
denis brogniart
cette photo a failli lui coûter la vie
qu'est ce que c'est que l'info valérie
tu peux réagir ma chérie bien sûr quand
tu veux tu ne fais pas là-dessus à leurs
photos c'est celle qu'on voit à côté où
il est malin en bas non non non cette
photo dont on va parler a failli lui
coûter la vie il a alors nul amulettes
non merci trois qu'on reproche à denis
brogniart de la pop ne pas avoir
respecté les des sommations social sur
un style army bois pour marc denis
brogniart était loin de s'imaginer que
la photo qu'il allait publier sur son
compte instagram allait faire polémique
sur cette photo prise après un match de
tennis de nombreux internautes ont
reproché à denis brogniart de ne pas
avoir respecté les règles de
distanciation social regarder il avec
arnaud 10.6 paul qu'un très beau joueur
qu'il dtn en plus un ancien joueur
français qui jouent très bien au paddle
aussi que j'embrasse arnaud il avec
amandine hesse que je connais très bien
aussi avec qui j'ai joué souvent et
kristina mladenovic qui est une grande
championne également voilà c'est trois
très gros joueurs ça et amandine je fais
des groupes amandine on a souvent joué
ensemble et amandine la balle fracasse
cki excès qui est devant elle sait très
bien qui est devant amandine j'ai pas
besoin de lui dire les chiffres comme il
comprenait cette polémique parce que sur
les réseaux ça a été un fracassage total
galli alors malheureusement je la
comprends et c'est pour ça oui je
comprends la polémique parce que il fait
partie des personnes aussi qui ont prôné
la distance sociale comme nous tous et
on peut là c'est une erreur de sa part
et je pense qu'il le conçoit lui aussi
que ces erreurs et c'est vrai que sur
les réseaux on se rend pas compte qu'on
ait vu par départ beaucoup de personnes
et même moi je fais attention à ce que
je poste parce que même si je fais
attention aux distances sociales
les gens ne connaissent pas notre vie
privée y pays savent pas si le matin
même la personne bas s est fait elle
s'est fait tester ou quoi qu'est souci
on a été confiné que cette personne
les gens connaissent pas notre vie
privée donc voilà je suppose qu'il n'a
pas été confinés que ces personnes là
mais on connaît pas la vie privée on
connaît pas l'envers de la photo bon bah
à un moment donné ça se trouve ils se
sont dit on se trouve pas derrière on
respire pas enfin je sais pas j'ai
surnommé après bien sûr personne n'est
parfait et on fait vraiment du mieux
qu'on peut même y sis au plateau un mais
parfois on peut faire des erreurs ça
arrive et diners il a supprimé ce
programme vous dire ça c'est important
les yeux de toute façon ça mérite pas de
fracasser c'est toujours pareil quoi
c'est le curseur est là bas ils
faisaient au toit si je déteste la
violence des réseaux believe we re -
l'abattoir ce qu'on fera qu'assez c'est
sûrement les mêmes qu'on fait un
barbecue ce week-end parce qu'on a
beaucoup été voir les potes on a bon
c'est beaucoup quand les parcs et
jardins non pas sur les bords de seine
où je sais pas où et c'est vrai que
parfois tu mets pas les distances plus
ou moins donc là c'est parce que c'est
denis brogniart et parce que c'est denis
brogniart il doit montrer l'exemple
parce que c'est pour ça que j'ai vu que
j'ai vu peu cuite wave anthony brogniart
il n'a pas le collier d'immunité
[Musique]
il n'a pas gagné l'épreuve de confort il
n'a pas le droit d'être côtés des autres
ouais c'est bon dans mon bar on va
clôturer le débat là dessus on va passer
à un autre sujet puisqu'il nous reste
maintenant les chérifien deux minutes
regardez c'est sur elie semoun regarder
dans ici bava elie semoun elie semoun
il perd tout alors il y semoun il perd
tout qu'est ce qui s'est passé pour elie
semoun notre pote qu'on aime énormément
de le faire elie semoun
il perd tout alors il faut savoir que
l'on se calque sur les titres voilà
déclic les [ __ ] à cliquer amer entendu
voilà qu'est ce qui se passe il perd ses
cheveux il perd ses cheveux non c'est
pas tout à fait ça non il
il avait récolté des sous pour un ehpad
et il a payé la paire bas du dos il a
changé de look
ouais c'est ça il a tout simplement
changé de nom en face à la gestion
capillaire compliquée durant le
confinement et à l'assaut voilà deux que
connaissent et l'aso connaissent les
coiffeurs elie semoun a craqué il s'est
entièrement rasé la tête lenaria posté
le résultat sur instagram regarder la
zkb salut salut passe entre nous et
ouais non mais sans rigoler on dirait
mon pote mickaël melliti lors des zones
ont soulevé la chaîne genre de laâyoune
magnifique il va très bien
ces murs habitué maintenant à l'éden à
côté un méchant lâche alors qu'il a une
tête de gentil et bunge rôle au cinéma
ouais non mais c'est vrai que leila
j'adore mon nom mais c'est vrai qu'il
bougeait bien ça les change vraiment te
tais c'est pas mal et je pense kelly
doit ce qu'il fait parce que s'il
autorise devrait pas poser la fois tu
sais que c'est une cata tu poses pas là
bien sûr errance qui s'est un petit peu
qu'il fait elie semoun tient à
l'escherichia kim kardashian regard des
petites en picardie
elle n'a vraiment pas de cul kim
kardashian au dessus kim kardashian
n'est vraiment pas que oui
kim kardashian a beaucoup de culot parce
que elle a créé ses propres masques et
les vents sur son site internet et se
fait du business sur le coroner très
bonnes réponses regarder ce qu'est ou
kim kardashian sa fille
non mais mon couler d'encre ça s'est pas
retiré cap si kim kardashian est une
reine de la com
en ces périodes de crise sanitaire il se
pourrait bien que la prêtresse de la
télé réalité est un peu perdu la main et
contrarié au passage quelques
internautes femme d'affaires aguerrie
depuis des années qu'ils mettent à la
tête de la marque de vêtements skins qui
réalise depuis son lancement des
millions de dollars de chiffre
d'affaires forte de ce succès la star a
donc décidé de lancer une gamme de
masques de protection fashion pour
lutter contre la propagation du covan
une initiative qui dérange de nombreux
internautes pour eux ces masques vendu 8
$ sont un business malsain sur une
pandémie mondiale comment osez vous
utilisez le coït 19 pour faire de
l'argent
vous devriez donner ces masques à des
hôpitaux des réactions qui ne semble pas
avoir beaucoup perturbé la star qui a
twitté quelques minutes après la mise en
ligne des masques non pas pour s'excuser
mais au contraire pour annoncer qu'ils
étaient déjà en rupture de stock comme
quoi polémique ou pas la mode reste la
mode la mode reste la mode et ouais
c'est fou ça ça a été une crise a créé
une polémique à trois missions pascal
pourquoi une polémique je viens lui
aussi des gens qui font le dérivé masque
8 euros il ya des matches qui vendra 15
balles les gens et on s'est fendillé
histoire aussi c'est pas bien mais je
veux dire si tout le monde le fait à le
rendre on supprime on leur dit de donner
alors tu vois il n'y a pas de noms mais
les profils comme à quel taux il était
basse et ça n'a pas besoin de ça à la
fois que je ne sers comme ça mais là non
seulement de chance à réussir un jeu